-Sofia Vergara,
we're gonna play this game
It's brand new.
It's called "7 in 7."
You have seven seconds
to name seven of something
The name will come up
randomly on your screen.
You'll see it, you'll know
what it is,
and then you'll have seven
seconds to name
seven of that thing,
and we'll see how many
we can get through.
I will go first, and then
let me tell you what my --
whew -- let me tell you
what my subject is.
Ready for this?
-Uh-huh.
-All right,
my first subject is...
Breakfast foods in seven
seconds, here we go.
Uh, eggs, bacon, oatmeal,
cereal, sandwich,
uh, uh, um...
[ Buzzer ]
Orange. Grapefruit.
-You lose, you lose.
It was seven minutes --
it was seven.
-All right. Okay, okay.
I don't --
I blanked on that.
Okay, I gotta focus.
Sofia, it's your turn.
-Okay, you lost already.
You lost already.
-No, no. I can win.
I never give up. Ready?
-Okay.
-It's your turn,
and your subject is...
Boy names. Boy names.
You have seven seconds. Whenever
you start talking, you go.
-Manolo, Juan Carlos,
Pedro, Augusto,
Arturro, Diego,
Francisco, Jose,
Adrian, Martin.
[ Bell dings ]
-Come on!
There was one in there tha
didn't sound like a boy name
There was like --
Adr-- the third one.
-Adrian? Adrian.
-Yeah. Oh, Adrian.
Ooh. Adrian. I like --
You just said it nicer.
All right, here we go.
Words that start with H.
Uh, uh, happy, heavy, hot,
heater, horny, heavy, handle
[ Bell dings ]
Uh, hot --
[ Laughing ]
-Can you say that word
on television?
-Why were you making that face
Look at your face.
Why do you keep making
that face? Stop it.
-You're not very good at this.
-Sofia, this is your round
-Okay.
-Words you'd shout
if you're mad.
You have seven seconds.
Words you'd shout if you're mad.
Go!
-[ Shouts in Spanish ]
[ Bleep ]
Eh...God damn it!
Son of a bitch!
Eh...
[ Buzzer ]
You stupid!
-Oh, my God!
Uhh, oh, my gosh.
We had to bleep all of that out.
-No.
-All right, this is round seven.
This is the last round.
Here's the way it works.
So we'll get the subject,
and then I will go then you go
then I go then you go,
same subject until we get 14
-Okay, don't mess this up.
Okay.
-I won't. Okay, here we go
Ready? Whew.
The subject is
names for a cute puppy.
Okay, I go first.
Bubbles.
-Petunia.
-Uh, uh, uh, tulips.
-Baguette.
-[ Stammering ]
Sorry, Candy.
-I mean, we're losing time
[ Buzzer ]
[ Shouts indistinctly ]
-[ Laughing ]
I can't think of a cute puppy --
name for a cute puppy.
-Lucky! Lucky!
Those are American ones.
Every dog in the United States
is Lucky.
Say it!
-Lucky.
Uh, Sofia, I think we got this
-Okay, perfect.
-Thank you so much
for doing this.
I'm so sorry. My kids came in.
I'm sorry.
-Thank you so much.
Give them a big kiss for me.
Thank you for having me.
-We love you, buddy.
Thank you so much for this
and congrats on everything
I hope to see you soon
in person.
Bye.
-Keep safe.
-Keep safe, everybody.
-Thank you. You too.